[Musik]
franziska quadri ist tetraplegiker aus
eigener kraft kann sie nun noch ihren
kopf bewegen
eigentlich mein körper einfach rein ein
brennend stechende schmerz also vor ort
an und er war inzwischen und der ganze
körper spüren und das ist einfach ein
schmerz und die spinnen lebensfroher
mensch und jetzt einfach sage ich dir
verletzung und ich hatte starke
schmerzen und ich will letzten immer
aber nicht
[Musik]
wie legt man wenn der eigene körper ein
schmerzendes gefängnis ist
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
der eintritt in franziska quasi selbst
mutet gespenstisch an die türen ihrer
wohnung in zürich wipkingen öffnet sich
dem besucher wie von geisterhand
franziska kann sie von ihrem wetters mit
einer bewegung des hundes öffnen
andere sind es konkret sie immerhin
gerade hüfte aus ziemlich stück
ringerinnen trotz ihrer schweren
behinderung lebt franziska quadri nicht
in einem heim sondern in einer
mietwohnung in zürich die nächte
verbringt sie regungslos und allein am
frühen morgen und am abend wird sie von
der spitex gepflegt für die betreuung am
tag hat franziska quasi zwei
assistentinnen angestellt was aussieht
wie gewollte bewegungen sind
muskelverkrampfungen sind spastiker das
sind so viele informationen sehen kann
heute berühren wir nicht wirklich
verarbeiten und dann reagiert
das ist ja sehr schmerzhaft vor allem
die kombination mit einer
neuropathischen schmerzen wohnungen ist
das ziemlich gut sein kombination mit
einer neuropathische schmerzen sehr
schlimm
und vor allem wie lange der gleichen
position klage bin und dann treibt wird
dennis anschlussstelle morgen früh noch
um letzte wenn zwei drei stunden die
gleiche position zu finden sind die
freilich noch viel extremer
wird die spastik zu heftig bringt den
joint vorübergehend etwas erleichterung
franziska quadri ist präsidentin des
medical cannabis klappt zürich und setzt
sich dafür ein dass kranke und
behinderte cannabis legal konsumieren
und in geprüfter qualität beziehen
können
ich nehme ja vor allem anna kallabis
tropfen und in kombination mit dem
rauchen shops wenigstens die da geben
wir zu überstehen
also ja ich muss so sagt cannabis
tropfen die habe ich mit dem
spezialrezept wurde
swissmedic über den ort der muße
halbjahr aus dem bericht schreiben und
das remis legale über das und die
raucher das muss ich mir egal ob illegal
besorgen
ich nehme spastik medikament das ist ein
besuch muskulatur entspannt und die von
früheren raue mit schmerzmittel über
aber das hat einfach eine kurve was ich
so lange das bringt gar nicht geschmeckt
so nicht ja und dann einfach gemerkt
dass mir das eine gute das system stört
für bin ich stolz drauf dass es mehr
oder weniger haben mit dem cannabis
lösen
es gab viel besser ich wieviel klar im
kopf spiel weniger mühe
und das ist schon ein riesenvorteil
franziska quadri ist 40 jahre alt als
sie noch gehen konnte arbeitete sie als
werberin sie hatte eine beziehung reiste
viel machte sport und ging auf partys
seitdem sie vor knapp sieben jahren mit
dem gleitschirm verunfallt ist dominiert
der schmerz ihr leben
der ganze dilemma der ganze stuhl das
ist ein problem ich lieder und eine
massive chronischen schmerzen wohnen
kann mit allem anderen kann man sich
irgendwie arrangieren und haben einmal
im rollstuhl sitzt manchmal sehr viele
möglichkeiten aber immer noch viel
machen aber die schmerzen mit dem
schmerz zusammen kombination ist es
wirklich jeden tag einfach nur ein
harter kampf
[Musik]
ihren linken arm kann franziska quali
noch schwach bewegen
kippt man ihn an und hält sein gewicht
malt sie solche bilder
ja
es geschah am 17 mai 2009 beim starten
riss eine windboe franziskas klatschen
ein paar meter in die höhe
darauf stolperte sie und stürzte
kopfüber auf eine wiese beim aufprall
brach ihre halswirbelsäule
es lag ganz am anfang haben die nummer
bringt also einfach nur dort ruhig sie
und nachher wechselten dass irgendwo in
der wird aktiv in den haag die augen
sagt die andere
irgendwann wird dann versucht oder wie
die künstler durchaus genügen
das sind wirklich so verschiedene
gefühlsebene wo moderator und hüte so
dass sie ja ich glaube ich ärgere mich
darüber dass das wirklich einfach hinter
miller und setzte so ohne wie es ist das
mache ich mir wirklich krank fallen
besonders schlimm sind ihre schmerzen im
kalten und feuchten schweizer winter
aber franziska hat einen plan
in der hoffnung auf linderung fliegt sie
für zwei monate in die wärme der kanaren
teneriffa
franziska hat im süden der insel eine
rollstuhl gängige finca gemietet es ist
mitte februar und franziska lebt jetzt
schon einen ganzen monat in der sonne
ihre eltern und ihre persönliche
assistentin begleiten sie für zwei
wochen ist auch ihre schwester andrea
angereist zusammen mit einer freundin
damit franziska die insel erkunden kann
sind ihre eltern in franziskas
behindertengerecht umgebauten kleinbus
vorausgefahren in der schweiz fährt
franziska nur auto wenn es anders nicht
geht
zu heftig sind die schmerzen welche die
erschütterungen verursachen
dezember folgt und auch mehrheit der
heimat andere mit seinem ford burgau
und ja da ist es eigentlich ganz anders
stärken ich kann einfach viel mehr
energie und ist kühl ich bin weniger
behörde und doch in hamburg höhnische
richtigen vertragen
das kleine alle frankfurt ihre ziel des
ausflugs der pico del teide francesco
totti und assistentin theres fotos
teilen sich die aufgabe franziska in die
seilbahn zu bringen
für weitgehend selbständiges leben zahlt
franziska quadri einen hohen preis die
löhne ihrer zwei assistentinnen zahlt
sie aus ihrer eigenen tasche mit ihrer
rente krankenkasse und
unfallversicherung übernehmen lediglich
die dienste des spitex weil sie sich die
unterstützung durch ihre assistentinnen
uhr an sechs tagen pro woche leisten
kann müssen die sonntage und die ferien
der assistentinnen von den eltern
abgedeckt werden
in der schweiz ist franziska korte am
liebsten zu hause und empfängt dort
ihren großen freundeskreis ihre wohnung
verlässt sie meist nur für arztbesuche
und therapien auch in den ferien war sie
seit ihrem unfall noch nie in den vier
wochen auf teneriffa habe sie mehr
unternommen und erlebt dass in den
ganzen langen jahren zeit den unfall
sagt franziska das auch so viel lüth das
finde ich schon immer gewöhnt ich
beruflich am ball und am stuhl sind das
nicht ich genieße das mega das klingt
jetzt zwar nach unten sie also nicht
noch einmal so ein vergnügen
tja sie schaut sobald halten wird mit
dorf kracht unglaublich haben in die
finger rinnt in der tasche der anfangs
ziemlich auffällig verkrampfen und
danach an ich verstehe sitzen und ja es
ist trotz allem aber die aussichten die
strukturen
dass ich doch nicht
in zürich übernehmen franziskus
funktionierte eltern jedes wochenende
ihre betreuung und auch hier auf
teneriffa unterstützen sie ihre tochter
bedingungslos und ich mir nicht erzählt
was das würde es den fonds zügig sich
nicht zu hause und dann machen wir das
eben hier eine geraucht aber ich muss es
dann vielleicht wieder probieren
in spanien ist in einheimischen der
besitz von cannabis für den persönlichen
gebrauch erlaubt touristen wie die quad
ist allerdings bewegen sich in einer
rechtlichen grauzone
weltkrieg vor dem cannabis bietet eigene
tochter und hat schon einiges dritter
klasse und muss sagen ja warum mit
mythos braucht für medizinische oder zu
sichern wir für einen schönen abend
machen reisen glas und so kommt es dass
der erklärte trugen gegner francesco
quadri für seine tochter in einem der
diversen cannabis clubs der insel auf
einkaufstour
[Musik]
mit dem ruf
die finca es liegt mitten in einer
bananenplantage und ist rollstuhlgängig
ein kleines stück freiheit wird ablege
karin franziska und das risiko wird der
ehemaligen ddr gelaufen für ihren sport
der besitzer der ferienhausanlage ist
ein freund von franziska und ebenfalls
tetraplegiker darum kommt sie vor ort
beinahe jeden tag in den genuss von
therapien wie sie in der schweiz nicht
kennt und als eineinhalb stunden
physiotherapie mit zwei therapeuten hier
gerade mal 85 euro kosten kann sie sich
dieses training auch viel öfter leisten
aus zu hause
es ist unerlässlich dass die aus dass
alle ohren glück braucht
dritter wurde nicht nur wenig funktionen
haben
das macht mir also diese einfach mal gar
nicht
mit meinem leben installiert
diese 50 also die handys an ihn haben
wir immer unsere jugend therapie gemacht
und der spieler kann ich dann nicht so
eine lage aber jetzt ist vollkommen
unglaublich einfach habe dem otto kopp
sachen ehepaar ohne dass irgendwo in der
nicht vom mega freud ich fahr mal im
louvre grinst aber nicht mit denen
schafe bin ihr unfall hat franciscos
ganzes umfeld verändert so auch ihre
jüngere schwester andrea habe mir
geschworen nach dem was passiert ist mit
der front sie das ja kam mama geht ihm
aber wann in der krise wieder danke ich
ralf schlage ich kann machen was ich
will
die schnitte ausschlachten gerade noch
hatten uns die eigenen ja dass ich ganz
großes thema hat sich aber von sich
selber das wieder zu erlauben
sie sagen alles genießen das hat mir
echt leid
er hat mir das blut wie sie das wieder
auch ohne aber ich habe es gelernt und
ich glaube kann an der front sind die
größten angstmacher mit therapien kann
franziska wohl ihre muskeln stärken ihre
arme und beine wird sie dennoch nie mehr
wirklich bewegen können in den letzten
jahren ist zwar immer mehr gefühl in die
gelernten gliedmaßen zurückgekehrt
dadurch sind aber ihre neuropathischen
schmerzen heftiger geworden
wenn wir sie gar nicht gerettet sind ihr
das immer so gedanken auch schon mal
drauf kommen also mit direktem einfluss
sieht dass die notorisch aber weil mir
das zu erleben
das rötliche herrmann ist
hochintelligent und das siebente spiel
ist natürlich warum sich schön kommen ob
er ballack und sie vielleicht nicht so
viel darüber weiß wie viel wir sind
einfach glücklich dass man sie nur hand
und und versuchen ihre zahl von ihrem
sinnieren
zum liegen
boston gegen die extrem gehen viele
körper fühlt sich gewinnen
weniger schwere und klemmt im wasser es
macht mir spaß
versöhnlicher spitze mit dem körper ja
also es ist weil ich so viel wie gelähmt
auf see oder wenn die klemmte er will
die das also zum teil schwere für
abstoßen
ob das gehört jetzt dazu es ist jetzt so
etwas mit anderen krank machen
das milde klima der kanaren hat seine
wirkung und franziska quasi nicht
verfehlt in der finca werden
auswanderungs pläne geschmiedet stilo
geht wirklich nach hause also mit den
letzten wochen merke was ist so dass es
so viele möglichkeiten hat was das
überhaupt will kosten und ob ich mein
körper mir gutes mir die kraft und ich
habe mich heute so freude eine therapie
wenn ich jetzt dass man wirklich einen
winter lang wird intensiv machen dass
mir noch einiges besser wirken jetzt
noch einmal träumen darf man ja mal
zwischen thiele
die insel hat franziska verändert in all
den schmerz kommt eine neue sorte
zuversicht für mich irgendwie schon
besonders schlimm ist so wenig verändert
sie benehmen so wie ich und wir nicht
groß gedanken gemacht und jetzt ist
schon wieder anders werden und ich
glaube das ist schon ein zeichen dass
sie bieten wir im labor nach oben haben
jetzt mit der situation und allem
irgendwas oder schlecht befunden dass
sie wirklich willkommen schritt weiter
gehen völlig doch noch irgendwelche
träume verwirklichen
[Musik]